Il n'est jamais trop tard pour agir
contre la pollution plastique.
Juger qu'il est trop tard,
c'est défaitiste et considérer
qu'il faut laisser le phénomène s'amplifier.
Or, on sait que ses impacts sur le climat,
sur la biodiversité, sur la santé humaine
sont particulièrement dramatiques.
Donc, ne serait ce que pour cette raison là,
ne baissons pas les bras et agissons
contre la pollution plastique.
Il y a ce qu'on voit, c'est-à-dire
qu'en France on est peut être habitués
malheureusement à voir un certain
nombre d'objets en plastique
traîner dans l'environnement,
que ce soit dans nos rues
ou dans l'environnement naturel.
Et la pollution plastique n'est pas que ça.
C'est aussi la pollution par les microplastiques
qui est beaucoup moins visible
et qui envahit les océans
et d'ailleurs tous les milieux terrestres
puisqu'on en trouve dans les océans,
on en trouve en haut des montagnes,
on en trouve dans les sols,
dans les rivières
et on voit bien que les origines
de la pollution plastique,
dans un pays tel que la France,
ne vont pas du tout être les mêmes
que celles d'un pays africain
qui va recevoir des déchets
qui lui sont envoyés en masse.
Et la France a d'ailleurs
porté un certain nombre de lois
pour agir en la matière
et elle doit aujourd'hui
essayer d'entraîner le plus de pays dans le monde,
dans la communauté internationale,
pour suivre sa voie.
L'enjeu, c'est de savoir comment
on va réussir à embarquer 175 pays
dans ce traité international.
Il vise trois objectifs :
le premier, c'est de dire que la pollution plastique,
ce n'est pas uniquement
ce qu'on voit dans les océans.
Que la pollution plastique,
c'est tout au long de la chaîne de vie des plastiques,
de l'extraction du pétrole
jusqu'à la gestion
des objets en plastique
lorsqu'ils arrivent en fin de vie.
Et le troisième grand principe
porté par le traité international,
c'est celui de dire
que la gestion de la pollution plastique,
ce n'est pas uniquement
la gestion des déchets
et donc le recyclage.
Et avant le recyclage,
on a la réduction, le réemploi,
la réutilisation.
Ce qui compte aussi,
c'est donc la réduction de ces plastiques
et quand on parle de réduction
on cible, notamment,
les emballages plastiques à usage unique
et notamment
ceux qui aujourd'hui ne servent à rien.
On a tous cet exemple en tête
de l'orange vendu sous plastique,
épluchée et vendue en quartiers,
alors que jusqu'alors
on a toujours réussi à consommer
des oranges.
Il faut désormais que ce traité
international arrive rapidement.
Son horizon temporel, c’est début 2025.
Il faut désormais
que l'ensemble des pays
réussisse à s'accorder,
à trouver des points de convergence pour arriver
à ce traité international juridiquement
contraignant pour mettre fin
à la pollution plastique
pour éviter que la planète
ne devienne,
comme elle est aujourd'hui,
une poubelle à ciel ouvert.